we've watched the show we've seen the
strategies we know the memes
[Music]
but has anyone actually stopped to ask
the question could a death tournament
like squid game actually be legal sure
there are people dying for cash which
immediately seems illegal but then again
those contestants signed a contract they
even opted their way back into the game
after voting to exit knowing full well
that their lives were on the line not
only that but the whole thing has taken
place on an island that belongs to
well we don't know who it belongs to but
is it outside of legal jurisdictions can
it be so again i asked the question
could the squid game be legal let's just
say that the answer isn't as clear-cut
as you might expect and may come up in a
big reveal for season two
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
where today i'm taking a brief time out
on the squid game to introduce theorist
holiday merch it's cool and warm at the
same time and has some of our most
unique pieces ever including this neon
green switch case this incredible satin
souvenir jacket black and white joggers
and t-shirts for when you're doing your
best impression of a piano and if you
need to stay warm boom quilted jacket
need to layer up with something a bit
lighter boom asymmetrical hoodie that
was actually designed by a member of the
film theorist community no joke they
actually submitted this design as fan
art over on the game theater subreddit i
loved it so much that we reached out to
her purchased the design and here it is
now translate it into an actual article
of clothing not only is this one of my
favorite design pieces that we've just
done from a design standpoint but to
know that it came from a member of the
community makes it all the cooler ah
this one makes me so happy it's like
walking around in a big old hug and for
the truly loyalist of loyal theorists
don't forget to bring it all home with
an incredibly snuggly four-channel
fleecy blanket this thing is perfect for
game night or you know on those
occasions when you're netflix and
chilling and the action on screen gets a
little bit too intense for your eyes
squid game is uh pretty mature so hide
from the action on screen with this
blanket there is so much more too that i
haven't even mentioned but most
importantly of all we ordered all of
this merch well in advance to avoid all
the supply chain issues that are
happening right now for the holiday
season so when you order you're gonna
get your gifts fast so they can appear
under the tree and you can use them all
year that said the other side to that
coin is once we're gone we are just out
it is very very hard to order stuff
right now and get it in a reasonable
amount of time so if you are interested
in any of these items i encourage you to
get it immediately because the supplies
are extremely limited and that's not me
doing the whole like artificial scarcity
oh no you got to get them before no we
just ordered what we thought we could
sell and so you know if one item tends
to do really well it's it's just gonna
go and it's gone anyway this stuff is
gorgeous the materials are so high
quality everything is stitched in it's
an incredible lineup of merchandise if
you guys have ever bought theory ware
from us in the past you know how high
quality it is how long it lasts and how
much we care about the designs that
we're putting into your hands because we
see it as an extension of all the things
that we do on youtube and it's really
important for us to get it right and we
think that you are gonna love it you
will love it so check it out in the
merch self right below this video pull
it up in a new tab take a look after
this video is done i thank you so much
for your consideration now back to squid
game
obviously squid game needs no
introduction at this point i mean the
premise of get a bunch of people
together on an island and pit them
against each other in a series of
playground games in order to survive
just sells itself it is the most watched
netflix series of all time it's like on
that bird box it caused a huge surge in
demand for honeycomb candy pink
jumpsuits and white slider shoes and
it's prompting internet creators from
all over to make their own versions of
the game squid games in minecraft squid
games and roblox on tick tock squid
games with friends and before the end of
the year my buddy mr beast is doing his
own version with 453 contestants all
competing with the six games from the
show now obviously that's not gonna be
real but it prompts the question could
it be in other words jimmy and the rest
of the team aren't creating real death
games but if some aging super wealthy
bored guy diana brain cancer wanted to
arrange something exactly like this
complete with the death would there be a
legal way of doing it after all they
signed a contract waving their legal
rights so does that make the death game
legal what are the limits of contract
law can you legally consent to a death
game where the rules might result in you
plunging to your death well believe it
or not but the question of whether you
can legally consent to a death game is
something that has actually come up in
real life it sounds crazy right like
who's looking into this case law but
it's come up in numerous cases in the
u.s specifically with games like russian
roulette which disclaimer is a terrible
idea disclaimer and should never be
attempted ever flashing warning lights
awful awful stupid stupid dumb don't do
this but basically it's a game is not
the right word it is a stupid dumb dumb
stupid stupid thing where a single
bullet is loaded into an empty chamber
of a gun it's spun and randomized people
then take turns pulling the trigger
until the gun fires
loser is the one who dies now like i
said some really stupid dumb people do
this and they actually wind up dying but
in an interesting legal twist the other
individuals involved in that game get
convicted for manslaughter even when the
person who died is pulling their own
trigger and doing so voluntarily
participating in let alone running a
death game is not legal even if everyone
who's involved knows exactly what
they're signing up for which means two
things first that players voting
themselves back into the squid game
doesn't make things any more legal you
see in squid game's second episode after
learning that losing any individual
challenge means death the participants
vote to end the game only to realize
that the real world back home isn't that
much better than murder island as a
result many contestants voluntarily
choose to come back in for another
chance to play from that point forward
they're back of their own volition
knowing full well the sort of game that
it is and the incredible stakes that are
on the line but all of it doesn't matter
the games are going to be illegal
regardless but you know what that
decision does change it suddenly makes
every participant guilty for the first
game it could be argued in a court of
law that the players didn't know what
they were signing up for who would have
suspected that they'd be transported off
to a remote island in the middle of
nowhere and forced to contend with a
sniper-powered motion detector no one
that would have clearly been like their
what second or third guess as to what
was going on at that point in the show
they would have all been innocent but
coming back willfully knowing that this
was a game where their fellow
competitors were gonna die suddenly
they're guilty by association their
actions are perpetuating the game just
like in the russian roulette example and
they're indirectly or sometimes even
directly getting other people killed and
that meets the definition of
manslaughter even our hero gion who
actively tries to avoid killing anyone
throughout the series guilty were he to
alert the authorities about the illegal
death games his winnings would be seized
immediately and he'd likely have to go
to court to answer for all his crimes
over here in the u.s manslaughter
equates to anything between 3 and 20
years in prison so over 400 counts of
manslaughter for all the failed
contestants that's potentially 8 000
years in prison sorry guyon you're not
gonna need that fancy new hairstyle in
the lockup the us actually has a lot of
specific laws around things like games
that involve violence and the threat of
injury given our nation's history of
illegal pistol dueling as well as other
legal but still violent sports like
boxing that said all of those specific
rules generally fall under a few basic
legal principles that apply almost
universally and would almost certainly
apply to games hosted in south korea
like we see in the show or eu member
nations or pretty much any country on
earth one of those overarching guiding
principles is that you can't legally
authorize a contract for illegal
activities i mean nobody's stopping you
from printing out a piece of paper and
signing your name on it but the entire
point of a contract is to protect all
the parties involved for example in ohio
where i grew up there are hot wings
restaurants that have certain items on
the menu that require you to sign a
waiver before you'll be allowed to order
them if i were to order that menu item
and then try to sue the restaurant for
damages after i spent the next day on
the toilet they could just point to the
contract and say look this guy knew what
he was getting himself into it's not our
fault that his bowels are currently
erupting like mount vesuvius but you see
that agreement wouldn't protect them
against any criminal charges that would
be held against them like criminal
negligence or reckless endangerment
which are crimes that you go to jail for
for example even if i signed the waiver
saying i consent to whatever you give me
to put in my mouth the restaurant can't
knowingly serve me expired food or rat
poison or other things that would
violate health codes and or actually
pose a serious threat to my life and
safety regardless of whatever legalese
they put into that contract doing stuff
like that is just illegal and no amount
of putting it on a piece of paper and
getting other people to sign it is gonna
make it any more legal the long and
short of it is that no contract is gonna
change the fact that illegal things are
just still illegal you can't consent to
getting killed for money as far as i can
tell it's true of every country's legal
system the us south korea anywhere else
but here's the real question that got me
thinking what if the murder games aren't
taking place on south korean soil what
if there as we see in the series being
hosted on a private island as we've
stated this would be illegal in any
country but is there a way to escape
national boundaries and host death games
such that those laws don't apply to you
well i sat down did the research and the
question of what laws apply outside of
national borders is actually a lot more
complicated and also a lot more
interesting than i expected first off
going to your own remote island even if
it is privately owned isn't going to
legally help you in fact the term
private island is kind of a misnomer
yeah you can have an island that's your
own private property but that doesn't
automatically make it legal for you to
do whatever you want there i mean think
about it this way i own a house that is
my private property but that doesn't
mean that i can just start cooking meth
down in the basement my so-called
private property is still legally under
the jurisdiction of the us government
the same is true for private islands
every piece of land on earth has been
claimed by some nation so what if you're
not on land how about international
waters the fabled high seas where
supposedly there are no rules because
you're beyond the bounds of any nation
well first you gotta get there nations
not only own their land but also govern
the immediate water around them the
coastal waters of each nation are what
are known as territorial waters which
according to a 1982 united nations
convention extend 12 nautical miles away
from the coast there's also an exclusive
economic zone that extends 200 nautical
miles 370 kilometers or 230 regular
miles because for some reason nautical
miles and just miles miles are different
apparently that difference makes it
easier to measure longitude and latitude
anyway beyond those 230 miles away from
the shore then you've reached
international waters and the idea of
floating out into international waters
to get away with your illegal death game
isn't as outlandish as it might for seem
after all many cruise ships have casinos
that only operate when the ship is
sailing in international waters that
seems like it should be a case of using
the international waters loophole to
circumvent the law but it's not you see
that's just a common misunderstanding
according to international law any
vessel at sea has to be registered to a
country whose flag they then carry if
you fly a south korean flag you're
governed by south korean law if you fly
a u.s flag you're governed by the united
states law so let's go back to the whole
casino example this isn't a matter of
the law not applying to the boat but
rather different laws applying to the
boat at different distances from the
land once a ship crosses into the
territorial waters of a country or state
where gambling isn't allowed those
casinos on board need to be shut down
because now they're technically playing
by that territory's rules out in
international waters the casinos are
able to reopen because now the boat is
following the federal laws of whichever
country's flag they fly but even in
those international waters you can tell
that certain rules are still applicable
the casino is still closed to people
younger than 21 in accordance with u.s
law or if it's flying a flag from a
country with more permissive gambling
laws like the uk then the casino could
be open to people as young as 18. and by
the way you can't get around this by not
flying any flag in fact not flying a
country's flag makes you even more
suspicious and under international law
any other country's vessel can board
your vessel inspect it and then arrest
you when they see the mountain of
corpses that have been piling up over
the course of your death game and even
if nobody catches you while you're at
sea the moment that you pull into a port
well then you can get arrested for any
of the crimes that you've committed odds
are that you're gonna have to pull up to
port at some point for i don't know
things like clean water more eggs
tempered glass panes some bleach to
clean out the bloodstains from your
uniforms there's a lot of stuff you're
gonna need to restock and if your plan
around that is i'll just stay out at sea
and have everything delivered to me well
anyone who delivers is aiding and
abetting you and will then get the
handcuffs slapped on them come on why
can't a guy just do one simple thing one
simple thing like giving people the
chance to get out of their financial
destitution by forcing them to put their
lives on the line while rich investors
bet on the winners and losers like
horses in a race
this is why we can't have nice things
fine i can't do it on land i can't do it
in a vessel on the sea what if i create
my own freaking country after all me and
my poorly acted friends are rich we're
so rich and so bored that we spend our
money doing stuff like this so why not
create a new island where we can
continue doing stuff like this and not
have to worry about some government
coming to slap cuffs on us artificial
islands are already a thing numerous
countries including japan the
netherlands india and austria have all
created artificial islands most of them
exist to serve as airports but one of
japan's artificial islands is home to
hotels a convention center they even
have an ikea so what if you go out into
international waters and build your own
artificial island there can i build my
own country that disregards all the
rules create giant games of deadly
tug-of-war build slides with no hider
safety restrictions construct railings
that have uprights that are more than a
foot apart
spooky and dangerous but i can do it
because it's my country and i can play
by whatever rules i want and you see now
we're getting somewhere this is actually
a topic that's seriously being discussed
today in fact it's the basis of a
movement known as seasteading this idea
has been floated
by organizations like the seasteading
institute as well as private companies
like blue seed which aim to float a ship
near silicon valley that would allow
entrepreneurs from around the globe to
gather and work on startup businesses
without being at the mercy of the visa
system and taxes a project i gotta say
sounds like the most silicon valley
thing ever and also one that's been on
hold since 2013 due to quote
insufficient funding come on you're
telling me that no tech billionaire has
the money to get this thing off the
ground literally because it's going to
be out in the water jeff bezos where are
you at bro i guess he chose space over c
and you see there might be a good reason
for that the question of whether you can
start your own country and get
recognized as a sovereign state is an
absurdly complicated topic with tons of
legal implications that remain
unanswered on account of nobody actually
making a serious effort to do that sort
of thing but luckily we don't need to
get into the nitty-gritty about that
today because we only need to know one
basic and simple fact you can't escape
international law by starting your own
country there's such a thing as
universal jurisdiction that covers
certain universal crimes like human
trafficking torture and other human
rights violations that you can get
arrested for while traveling through
international waters the entire point of
this is to designate crimes against
humanity as a set of standards that
everyone is held to even if a country
might define them as illegal on their
land in the past these universal
jurisdictions have been invoked to hold
military leaders responsible for war
crimes or hold government officials
accountable when they're responsible for
acts of genocide so
death game yeah it's not gonna fly
having your participants sign a contract
doesn't work buying your own private
island doesn't work taking to the high
seas doesn't work even creating your own
country doesn't work but there is still
one final option here and this one sadly
does work and that's being so powerful
that the rules don't apply to you
everything that we've talked about today
is the way that things should be but
sadly as i'm sure we're all aware of in
the real world despite the existence of
international law and universal
jurisdiction and things like that plenty
of countries still commit human rights
violations and get away with it even
though we'd expect things like universal
jurisdiction to allow organizations like
the un to intervene in cases of human
abuse the grim reality is that actually
going in and arresting the officials
responsible is sometimes impossible
without risking wars that would result
in many more deaths especially when
nuclear powers are involved case in
point north korea continues to commit
numerous human rights abuses something
that the united nations human rights
council has spent years investigating
with a recent report in 2020 based on
100 first-hand accounts this is the kind
of thing that universal jurisdiction
provisions under international law
should prevent but don't because north
korea as a nuclear power is able to get
away with it now when it comes to heavy
subject matter like this i'm always
going to hesitate to draw comparisons
between fictional stories in real life
because i don't want to do it in a way
that's going to trivialize the death and
suffering of real people but i do think
in this case that it's actually
reflective of one of the central themes
featured in squid game regardless of how
illegal something might be the people
responsible for torture death and
absolute brutality can get away with it
simply by how powerful they are by
having a character from north korea who
participates in the squid game
specifically because she wants to help
her family escape from the brutal regime
the show is directly drawing attention
to that in fact given how willing the
show has been to address this topic in
season one by prominently featuring a
north korean defector as one of its
central characters it wouldn't surprise
me at all if we were to find out in the
inevitable season two that the games are
actually held on an island under north
korean jurisdiction well there is no
legal loophole that i could find that
would make the squid games legal the
real world has shown us that it doesn't
matter how illegal your actions are if
you're operating under the authority of
certain corrupt regimes and given their
track record it wouldn't surprise me to
see north korea turning a blind eye to
the ultra wealthy organizing games where
people are killed for sport as long as
they get to see a cut of that money
setting the games on an island under
north korean jurisdiction not only
logically makes sense from a
geographical plot-based and
world-building standpoint but would also
fit in with the themes that the show is
already exploring in its first season
and that my friends is the sad and
complicated truth of the squid game
while it might seem stupid to ask the
question of could something like this be
legal the real world answer to that
actually matters a lot because it's
happening around us each and every day
but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and just one final reminder that
that merch is available right below this
video if you are interested at all in
getting more film theorists specific
merch that amazing asymmetric hoodie
designed by a member of the film theory
community is available right now if you
want to see more film theory merch down
the line showing your support for that
item actually tells us hey people want
to wear their film theory pride because
up till now they've just really liked
the neon green and black and so we've
leaned in on that but support film
theory friends that's your item and as a
reminder if you order early you'll be
sure to get that before the christmas
season which is you know difficult to do
nowadays for a lot of people but we've
taken care of that in advance so anyway
thank you all so much for watching and
i'll see you in the next video